[Music]
where is the i had a brendan shop thing
where is it
the was he uh
frozen can you send that to me i might
have accidentally closed it
oh i did send you something that
somebody sent me okay i got this okay
what did you send me in show links
um
just a fan had sent me um they they
bought something at the store
the chips
that uh
they wanted to share with me they're
like i bought these and i thought of you
guys
oh
yeah okay okay this is this this
this will go this will go perfect this
will go perfect with this segment okay
if somebody dm'd me on instagram it was
like hey i thought of you guys i saw
these at the store i had to buy them
okay so what we have here let me pull
this up on the screen so we could see it
we have uh
if you guys are hungry and you want a
little snack yeah you could get a little
snack you get some book of a gun
be called
a local fan just bought those just
because of our stuff are they good
i'm one i'm just curious they're good no
i can't imagine good they sound pretty
good right maybe but the problem with
pika the guy or what makes it so good is
also the texture of like all the stuff
so just like having it a flavor seems
kind of weird
he's working on
he's working at new and new material
the laugh factory eh yeah
looks like there's gonna be layoffs
looks like they're shutting down the
factory this is the worst thing that's
happened to the laugh factory since
michael richards was there
okay you ready
newsome set today on ktla shout out to
ktla newsome
hold on did you hear the waste
already do we have to do you hear he
said do some hold on
newsome set today on ktla shout out
knew some piece of [ __ ] but um
handsome devil though handsome [ __ ]
dude i'll give him that
why are people laughing he hasn't joked
yet oh she went so [ __ ] handsome
scott looks like his son what are you a
[ __ ] model you're distracting dude
he's doing hey murr she's doing
i know you don't know a lot about the
craft
i know you're not into the craft well
then enlighten me okay i'm going to
you know i was talking with uh fellow
comedians um
in the craft the other day i think it
was ryan long and danny polishek we were
talking about the crafts thinking and
hanging out
god that's all they talk about i know
all they talk about is a craft um
and they also give you the wrong
directions to their studio so um
[Laughter]
they were talking about the craft with
me they send you a [ __ ] one what
appears to be some sort of middle
eastern bazaar
exactly
that's what exactly what it looked like
so anyway i was i was thinking about the
craft and i was like you know what this
is called merch this is called crowd
work um
so what happens like when you're such a
good comedian you could go off script
you know yeah you just work the crowd
you know starve is very good at that
yeah you go formerly of come town
uh you uh he's leaving do you sell that
yeah so somebody opponent posted a
picture why and they posted a picture of
stav with uh hassan [ __ ] and then uh
nick doing making a video with sam hyde
yeah boy they're going a different
direction
what
why would you have to be good looking to
do a voice
tim allen did a great voice and he's not
a good looking guy
sir you are breathtaking
i bet you that this is all pre this
isn't real crowd work by the way uh nice
oh this is all preconceived stuff yeah
he hasn't said anything
like real crowd work is you say
something and they say something right
you react to what they're saying he's
just going off about how he wants to
[ __ ] this guy apparently with his camel
toe man come on the pants don't have to
be that type brandon jesus christ
jesus christ that's what i just said
trying to contain this erection but
these [ __ ]
tight pants are giving it away
okay i hadn't seen this i've frozen have
i seen this before this is getting
really gay no i haven't i've not seen
this before
yes you all get a good look at this
gentleman out there i don't know
what you do man you want to [ __ ] this
guy yeah it's not even again guys this
isn't crowd work no this is like [ __ ]
grinder
the sky is the limit by man
i mean the next top gun oh my god dude
this can't be four minutes of this
[ __ ] sakes dude
on your helmet just says dime piece
that'd be [ __ ] sick oh yeah
pre-written
this is all pre-written does it
diamond piece of his crutches right
right just like ever just so happens
every time richard ross is on stage his
wife calls him on the phone
oh my god you ruined it for me you're
right
you didn't should know it's 10 30 at
night i mean where is he every night
you think you know by now right i've
been at three shows and it was the same
[ __ ]
i like voss i think he's funny i'm just
you know very funny you don't know
you're right
hey danny saint where's where's rich fox
performing this weekend
i don't know dude i'm starting to think
you are a little
i by the way brian here's the thing up
until this bit i didn't really think you
were but i'm i'm starting to feel like
you kind of are a little gay buddy
this would be a great time to throw him
off his game if you're in the crowd i
would think somebody would just yell out
do you want us to leave
you want us to just leave you two alone
a few drinks and it's going down homeboy
is he gonna [ __ ] this guy
apparently come on man
but that would be so great dude it's
like
because you know this is all pre-written
yeah of course and one little response
would throw his game totally off oh yeah
seriously yeah he all you'd have to do
is go all right [ __ ] him already and
then he'd be he'd be done and he'd be
like but this
um
what are you like some kind of like
volleyball guy or like you just keep
going and then you just have steve
hofstetter off stage sweating because he
can't roast the guy
oh i roast him i'm the rose guy i could
roast him
oh the socks i should be out there yeah
the people the people that he's roasting
aren't plants that's for sure
wow it seems like nobody has more
hecklers than steve hoffsteiner huh
it's weird [ __ ] weird
prince going down maverick you know what
i'm saying dude
i'll be your bottom gun you feel me
all pre-written and all bad
it's really gay
all written
all of it
and not worth a long laugh break like
this
look at the back of look at the back for
the ad ready
you're distracting dude
you're like a hot medusa get out of here
bro
um
medusa
i
why is he allowed in comedy clubs it's
medusa
m-e-d-u-s-a he's talking about the snake
thing right yeah you know medusa is the
wrestler oh okay
who threw you're
women's championship in the garbage yeah
get out of here bro you're like a hot
medusa first off medusa was like she she
had the snake hair thing but she like
you if you looked in her eyes you turned
into stone and of course it's not
spelled
m-a-d-u-s-a you dig out of my face dude
bro
suck it already christ man
let me try to kill i'm just gonna hold
this here so it blocks you out
you're one lucky lady you know what this
is bernie chubb
well yeah but brandon shop is a guy who
is bad at comedy he's one of those dudes
he's one of those dude
yeah but exactly
he's one of those dudes that like hangs
out with his buddies and they tell him
you should be a comic because he's like
conversationally silly
and he thinks that that could translate
to the [ __ ] to the stage
do not leave your man around me
okay you wanna [ __ ] dudes bro i get it i
tell you what have them blow you in your
f-150 raptor i mean that's fine but can
we have a like there's actual comedians
that have jokes they have prepared
[Laughter]
i'm kidding it's l.a
i've seen some of the women you try to
get to blow you i feel like the bar is
pretty low yeah hot people seriously
karate
i don't know if that means anything
quite the life brandon [ __ ] a lot of
girls that look like they're 35 year old
uh 35 year old hostess not servers
hostess yes
are you an actor are you a model oh my
god he's
two minutes bro it's been two minutes of
this dude
yeah it's weird dude he's hitting on
this guy a lot tommy hill figure out
when we leave here
first designer you could think of yeah
tommy hilfiger does anyone even wear
tommy hilfiger anymore i don't know man
puerto ricans maybe
the guy bro
you know who could use his abercrombie
don't just no you brought this now works
now we're gonna go i didn't bring this i
didn't bring this we're getting through
this i didn't bring this who did this
frozen frozen
yes
you son of a [ __ ]
i don't saw that documentary
they need some help
[ __ ] who couldn't you help
maybe i was actually going to see that
documentary brendan but you had it dmcad
so
couldn't couldn't watch it
brought to you by bent pixels
they're the all-time low man that
blackfish dock really [ __ ] up
what year is this that black fish stock
they're not it's june this is from this
is from two days ago three days ago
you remember that documentary from 10
years ago yeah when did blackfish come
out i want to see this guy's topical
2013
go easy on him all right he [ __ ]
that's probably the last time he didn't
have brain damage fair enough
that's why he's referencing tommy
hilfiger
oh he's like yeah dude [ __ ] myspace
it's like an always sunny when frank
fell out the window and thought it was
2006. yes what's your name
garrett [ __ ] yeah
and then [ __ ] charlie thought the
cure was to get him through the window
yes because he thought it was a time war
and he was just walking around with an
open wound in the back of his head yes
like brendan has open wounds on his
brain
garrett [ __ ] yeah why [ __ ] yeah garrett
i don't even know what this is
this i'll tell you what this is the
future of comedy
i thought they outlawed abortions
[ __ ] not in l.a
[Laughter]
l.a comedy cement safe boys oh this was
oh this was two days ago yeah yeah so it
was already illegal brendan's a felon
now he's out here operating illegal
abortions
let's break up a federal
hey brendan you can't you you know you
can't do this in [ __ ] texas when you
visit rokin
i'm just gonna put you in a bathing suit
come see garrett jump in the water
okay
i'm [ __ ] splashing around
oh he's doing the he's doing the the
wacky body movements now
you lost me
oh mercer's dude mercer's doing an
impression of the showtime rep when he
asked him he wanted a second special
what
and my big ass just cannonballs in and
[ __ ]
that's my man
just get through
it's gay
sea world gay
i don't
know what he's
trying to say
like usually he's just bad right
i don't even know
what he's trying to do
603 upvotes 3 000 down votes
i'm thick boy
[Music]
sorry man you're so distracted dude oh
you're still doing it the first first
ever having a crowd after seven years i
might have to export you out of here he
might have to escort him out of there
sometimes you gotta escort people out i
hate me gonna escort him out he's been
suffering with this remember since he
was a child he said the speech
impediment
well a lot of people don't notice he
joined the ufc when he was four oh that
makes sense that makes a lot of sense
actually yeah he was one of chuck
liddell's first opponents
which was very unfair to do to a kid
that's why he's so [ __ ] now it makes
sense and chuck liddell didn't hold back
he beat the [ __ ] out of him chuck
liddell wouldn't hold back even if you
put him in the room with a four-year-old
he'd kill him are you sure about this
and you're like yeah he's not he's not
going to get tough otherwise all right
beats the [ __ ] of him
dude
i can't focus man do you like ferraris i
have one
nice humble brag did you see what he
just did there
joe everyman
[Laughter]
he really pre-planned this bit
where was
i failing at being comedian
yeah
pretty much last last we left previously
on brendan job
oh yeah talking about handsome people
the shop household we can't go through
on our lockdown right now we're not
going to make it out of it
won't be locked down dude i'm just
saying if you want to lock down i'm i'm
he still wants to [ __ ] this guy
i think the people that are laughing at
him and encouraging him should be
arrested
you know there's nothing wrong with like
doing the whole gay thing right like you
know whatever the whole yell thing
that should be a 10 second thing
yeah you know what i mean that should be
like wow this guy's hot man i'm not even
gay but holy [ __ ] dude
like a little chuckle and then you move
on this has been just
an entire set about him wanting to blow
this guy yep
if they i'm gonna dm you dude
like hey man i'm thinking about lock hey
whoever's because this is on his thick
boy whoever's editing this on windows
movie maker
first off number one now that i know
that he's probably the one doing it you
sp you misspelled medusa
so you got to fix that brendan you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and
secondly
this whole making every video look like
a tick tock video is the worst
we're putting the putting the text over
a lot of people are doing this now and
it's very important well i know why it's
like when it plays when there's no audio
like on instagram or like on facebook
people could still read it and go oh
what's he saying you know
what do you think
can somebody just to [ __ ] around i don't
care one of you can you make like a clip
of ours and do this do the same thing
for us like put text i just want to see
how dumb it look i really want to see it
ugh
live
bunch
snacks like probably not much right i
what do of
hate sugar are you sugar or no you tell
me you're in the gushers
you're [ __ ] dude
god defend him
god people defend this hey brendan fans
defend him defend this yeah no please i
tell me explain the bit to me what are
we missing
explain the bit to me like i'm for
because every time they defend him as
he's a really nice guy i go okay
i i don't think so he went after bobby
lee with a vengeance and is suing you
know content creators but yeah
there's a lot of nice guys out there
that i'm not gonna let perform heart
surgery on me
let people just fly airplanes too like
oh my god why is this plane going down
as the pilot never flew a plane before
but he's a really nice guy the chest
bones connected to my wrist watch
[Laughter]
the ruse we're getting married
are we just gonna name childhood food
now i guess man i don't know [ __ ] i
don't know blow pop i guess starburst
sir i will lick your [ __ ] i'll say
that
what
he wants to put his tongue in this
gentleman's anus area
in or around i guess
where's the joke
standing on stage
you're looking at him
[Laughter]
well guys it looks like the laugh
factory's shutting down shipping all
those jobs to china honestly at this
point you should just call this place
the factory yes because this sounds like
joke that some [ __ ] in a factory will
be telling you
i hate to keep going your way but i'm
telling you dude
you name your prize daddy
again like you said it's one thing to
like
have a throwaway throw away but
maybe that guy the fact that that was
all pre-written
maybe maybe it's because maybe maybe
it's because um
maybe because that dude was a dime piece
do you think maybe i hate brendan no i
but the dime piece he puts me in a bad
mood